Good morning, golf.
Good morning, how are you?
Very good. How about you?
Good, good.
Troy, this morning I saw your message, so I added Max as well in all our upcoming service call and everything.
Great.
He's gonna join today, or...
Hopefully we'll see him. Yeah.
We will see him soon.
Kip.
He's going to join today, right?
Yes.
Okay, cool, cool.
No.
How's everything going?
Listen.
What's that?
How's everything going?
Good.
Good. Had a long weekend, didn't think about work much.
Sushant.
Last time, always think some, but not a lot.
Hey, Max.
Yeah.
Everyone.
Hey, Max, this is Aman.
Hello.
Yeah, first time, right? Yeah. All right, so I'll probably give my quick introduction. So I'm from like the service delivery side, who's closely going to work with Sterling, right, and day-to-day operation. If you need any support, technically, anything on site, everything, so I'm going to be the first point of contact for anything related to the service delivery on site.
We have Rick also, so Rick over to you.
Yep, so I'm Max. So my name is Rick and I've been working with ITBD by Design from last 13 years and I'm the onboarding manager helping with the onboarding.
Thank you. Great to meet you.
Yes.
Fantastic. Great to meet you both as well.
Sameer.
All right, so I think when I saw that you are connecting with the Sterling, so I think probably I'll ask Rob and Max, how's everything going so far?
So far so good. He seems like he's really invested in his work. I really enjoyed working with him so far. He's got a good head on his shoulders and he seems to be very thorough in what he does.
Glad to hear. Yeah, so and again, our team, the channel that we are already open, right? So if anything that you notice need immediate attention, right, feel free to chat on team. I can take quick action and connect if anything need from our side. So, so just give you overview of this, and we already discussed with Rob. So the purpose of these are weekly call to be where we're going to discuss ongoing performance, everything what.
Starling is doing any operation changes, challenges, anything. So that is the whole purpose of this weekly connect.
Yeah.
So over all the service delivery point, we will check everything, how he's doing, what all the area of improvement, what how we can make the process better, what are the things that he can work right. So on the back end, I will going to support him.
Perfect.
So I think initially this two week, normally we present the data, right? Like what all he's doing, right? When he started working on the tickets, handling project, different tasks, we kind of, I don't know, calculate those all and present as a deck to show you how he's doing, right? Make sure he's on track, we all are on the same page.
Yeah.
So in the first two weeks, we don't have anything there, but I just prepared one. I connected with him this morning to see how everything is going, what all achievement that he has completed. And Rob, thank you for the CDP plan. So I'll share that, give you a quick overview and take your opinion. So let me share my screen.
Ketan.
Let me know if you can see it.
Yep, I can see it.
Yeah, so again, this is again what information I collected from him based on that I have. So this is what he started, right, from day one. These all training and everything that he's doing, right, what we are planning for him. So this is so far that he has completed.
And I'll go to your CDP plan that you have shared.
Mhm.
So, so just we can the first immediate that you have mentioned about S.C. 300, right?
Yes.
Yeah, so second one we have planned for MS1 and 2. So I have prepared this plan for that. I'll share that with you so that we are on the same page. So this is what we have planned for him in stage one, what all that he's going to learn and cover under this complete course.
Mmh.
This will be immediately started, targeted. We are planning at least two months, right? The one person is going to be the training part where he's going to complete all these models and everything. And once the training part will be going to complete, then he's going to appear for the Microsoft certification and complete the exam.
So that is in the second phase. So that is in progress. So far he has completed as per the knowledge that he's already about this course. Based on that and a few topics that he already covered and he started preparing. So as of now, the progress I see 20%. So that's we're going to share with you every week how far he reached, what all progress that he's making, any challenges or anything.
Mhm.
So this is going to be again side by side, his daily tasks that he's doing, or going to deliver at your side. So it's not going to be that he's going to consume hours out of his regular shift and they're going to complete this, right? But the side by side, he's going to work on this. Once that'll be complete, then we're going to switch for the next.
So in the first stage, this is what I'll share with you. So timeline, three months, start in July and end September. Or do you think, and again, this is just I prepare based on the information I have, but I need to take your opinion. What do you think the timeline should be?
Mhm.
to complete or.
Um, I'm fine with that.
Yeah, but again, these can be changes if you, and again, whatever the roadblock or anything, if anything. So these all, he's going to complete and these all model he's going to complete. After that, we're going to move for the second phase, one or two. So of course, we expecting it.
And...
Yeah.
Three to 9, but yeah, but three to six, one or two is easy rather than SC300, so it probably already aligned with one or two, because he already completed the course and training part for the one or two, and he probably good to go for the certification part.
So, we don't just spend that much time on that, but just put a time here, so...
So you agree that he can probably beat that quite handily. He's much farther along in the 102.
Yeah, that's right. Yeah, because I had a discussion with him. So he already went through the course and training everything, right? And already working on that part in the previous client as well. So he's good aligned on the one or two side.
Yeah.
So yeah, but I put in a second phase, putting the first SC3 under on the immediate basis.
So, further they have to line then they define the development area, yeah, go please.
Well, it...
Is it the case where he can take the 102 and just get that done?
And then continue on the SSC 300.
Jack.
The Andrea? Yeah, definitely. So I think when...
Yeah, yeah. I mean, might as well put a bow on it and we don't have to think about it. And then he can continue on with the SC300.
Yeah, definitely. So I'll flip it to stage one, one or two, and then see 300 in the second phase. So I'll share this entire document as well, what all he's going to do.
Yeah.
Do you agree with that, Max?
Yeah, I do. I think that getting the 365 administrator quickly is a good call.
Okay.
I think it's also information he for the most part knows, so I agree that it should be a pretty easy lift for him.
Richard.
Yeah.
Correct, yeah, that's right. I know you already work on the migration project in the other task on the admin side on O36 device, so it'll be easy for him.
Right, I think that's what only I have from my side. Anything that you have planned, how is gonna, when are you gonna start working on ticket, what do you have planned for him, or still in progress?
Great.
Hmm.
We've got a couple of small projects that he's working on. He's working on a lot of automated tickets for us just to get more familiar with our clients and our ticketing system. Did a server migration with him on Friday that was pretty heavily supervised just to make sure that it was going smoothly.
So, so who's driving on that? Was were you driving or is he driving?
The server migration.
Yeah.
He was the hands, but there was a lot of asking questions.
OK.
OK, this, yeah, OK, as we expected, good.
I created the template and it was my scope, so I think it was a lot of, you know, him following my lead and saying, what are we doing next? So, but the document was pretty good and he was able to run with it. So I think that it was pretty straightforward, but I think it was anytime he came up with something he.
didn't know or wasn't certain about, he paused and checked in with me because that's what you're supposed to do in that space.
Mm.
Um, you know, if he's not certain, he's checking, which is fantastic.
OK.
Yeah.
will not do anything, rather doing something which is not aware.
Yes.
So, like, yeah, I know exactly right, and then that's what I ask him, yeah.
We'll take that.
End.
He's he's also do.
Yeah, he's also doing a small Windows 11 upgrade to systems, but it's a lot of communication and management. And then he's also shadowing a physical server install or migration. So those two things he's kind of participating in, just riding along.
But we then we have a mail migration coming up in early July that he's helping to design. So he's touching stuff.
Yep.
Yep, so part of his...
Yep, he's gonna be doing some discovery on that migration for us this week.
I can get.
So yeah, he's finally getting his hands dirty, so I'm sure that feels good to him.
Yeah, whenever he was excited to, I probably need to start working rather like training I can do it, but yeah. So I think I'm more excited to start working on it. I think another last piece probably, we'll take your opinion on that part, the KPH part, right? How?
One.
Mm.
We're going to measure him right what all the KPIs that he's going to work on it. So probably I was thinking maybe once he's fully aligned, you know, completely working in the eight hour shift, then probably we can define if you have already anything in place. So then yeah, let us know what all the criteria that we need to measure him. So make sure I can discuss with him and he's aligned and we're all on the same page.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Ketan.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, that sounds great.
Yeah, probably in about within two to three weeks, I would say it would have all that nailed down and it'll be...
Yeah.
fully working full-time.
Yes, I think that's what I have in my list. Rick, anything from your site you wanna add?
No, I'm good for now.
But it was great connecting again, Rob and Max.
Yeah, good seeing you, Rick.
Yeah.
Pleasure to meet you both.
Yeah, I think we're good. So again, we're not wait for a weekly call, right? If you find anything that need immediate attention, please feel free to ping on team, right? We can connect immediately.
Sounds great.
All right, thank you so much. Enjoy the rest of it, and take care. Bye.
All right.
Hey, Ketan.
All right, bye.
Thanks, guys.